the ripple effect of that huge win down
in federal court in Texas. Thank you,
Second Amendment Foundation. Thank you,
Firearms Policy Coalition that says that
if you're a member of FPC or SAF, you
can carry guns and post offices subject
to certain exceptions and whatnot. But
this is a big win. And I want to go back
and forth with some dialogue I had with
the Second Amendment Foundation on X to
answer some questions I posed that I
think will be helpful to you as a
practical matter moving forward. So
let's break down this important decision
and most importantly the effects of it,
the good effects of it on our second
amendment rights when we come right
back.
Hey folks, I'm Mark Smith, the host of
the four box of Dina, proud American gun
owner, constitutional attorney, member
of the United States Supreme Court Barn
and proud to say the top voice of the
second amendment in America back-to-back
years. Thank you. 2025 and 2026 Gundy's
awards. All right, folks. Before we talk
about uh some back and forth and some
further discussions that have occurred
involving this huge win, nationwide win
in fact, in the case of Fires Policy
Coalition, Second Amendment Foundation
versus Garland, now Bondi, the attorney
general, involving whether or not
American can carry guns in a post office
or whether or not the federal government
can ban guns in post offices consistent
with the second amendment. Before we get
to that, I want to let everyone know
that I'll be the keynote speaker uh next
week, I believe it's next Friday, out
there in Arizona at the Gun Owners of
America annual activist conference as
part of their conference they're having
at Gun Owners of America in Arizona. So,
if you're out there in the southwest,
uh, you know, the next week or so, uh,
take a look at the Gun Owners of America
website, take a look at the keynote
event, uh, the activist event, and the
keynote speaker will be Mark Smith at
the Farbox Diner. Uh, so, you know, take
a look at that, and if you're around,
make sure you try to stop by and say hi.
All right, folks. So, this is very
exciting news. We've already covered the
basic information which is that Judge
Rita O Connor, federal district court
judge in Texas found that the federal
government's ban on carrying guns in
post offices was unconstitutional under
the second amendment. This is clearly
the right answer for several reasons. We
don't need to belabor the point on that
right now. The federal government has
taken an appeal to the United States
Court of Appeals for the Fifth Circuit,
but I don't think they're going to do
that well there. Uh, nevertheless, that
is what's going on. So in short, you may
recall Judge Okconor said that it
violated the Second Amendment to ban
guns in post offices. There's no
comprehensive security there. It's not
like TSA. There's no historical
tradition of banning guns in anything
like post office at all. And therefore,
they cannot be banned. Then the question
became, what was the scope of the
remedy? Remember my rule. There is no
right without a remedy. You have no
rights without a remedy. So even if you
have this beautiful parchment paper that
says you have all these rights, none of
those are actual rights if you cannot
enforce them in a court of law. So if
there's a contract you have with someone
that says they're going to pay you $100
and no one will enforce it, you can't
enforce it yourself. So you don't really
have a right even if it says so in
writing. The reason why this is
important is that the Second Amendment
community won this big case in FPC,
Second Amendment Foundation versus
Bondi. And what happened was the lawyers
for the Department of Justice were
trying to narrow the scope of the
remedy. They were trying to narrow the
scope of who would benefit from this big
win for the Second Amendment. They were
trying to limit it to um certain
plaintiffs. But I'm happy to report that
Judge Okconor applying basic black
letter Supreme Court precedent from
years ago, from decades ago in fact,
said that current members of the Second
Amendment Foundation, current members of
Firearms Policy Coalition, and any
future members that f join in the future
FPC or the Second Amendment Foundation
will all be covered by this permanent.
This is a permanent injunction. This is
not a preliminary injunction. This is a
permanent injunction entered in favor of
the second amendment against the federal
government. And what that means is a
preliminary injunction is an injunction
that stops something or affects
something during the pendency of a
lawsuit that may go on for a couple
years.
A permanent injunction is what happens
at the end of a lawsuit as part of a
final judgment that says this case is
over. I've issued my ruling. Here's the
judgment. Here's who wins and here's
what they get or what they don't get.
Judge Rita O Connor and entering a final
judgment in this case involving the
Second Amendment post office question
entered a permanent injunction that says
the federal government with only a few
exceptions cannot enforce its post
office gun ban against the plaintiffs,
the organizations and the members of
those organizations and future members
of the organizations. Now, as a side
note, I think the reason why the Trump
administration
was fighting
the notion that people could join down
the road the organizations and still
benefit from this ruling is not because
they hate the Second Amendment or
anything. It's because the the
Department of Justice rightfully, it's a
legitimate concern. They're very worried
that the left-wing nut jobs that are
engaging in all this lawfare against the
Trump administration are going to
exploit every loophole and they're going
to be some, you know, random victory for
some illegal immigrant in, you know, the
Western District of Kansas or something
and next thing you know, every illegal
immigrant in America is going to join
that ruling and be governed by some
ruling by one district court judge. So
that I think is what the Trump
administration fears, which is why I do
think they're pushing back on the scope
of the remedy and our big Second
Amendment wins, which I don't like and I
don't support. But I do understand at
least the thought process here because
remember how I've explained to you brick
by brick by brick, precedent by
precedent by pre and the courts allows
other courts to use those bricks to use
those precedents to do other things in
other future cases. That is exactly what
this Department of Justice fears. That
there will be some sort of precedent set
that will in turn be used against the
Trump administration to shut down their
efforts to deport the tens of millions
of invaders that have come into this
country and need to go home in all
respects. Cuz as you know, there is no
more important issue to our Second
Amendment rights than kicking out all of
the illegal aliens and cutting back
dramatically on so-called legal
immigration, which in my view in many
instances is, shall we say, shady shady.
Nevertheless, that's a topic for another
day. Uh, now let's go on back to this.
So, after this big win, which I
announced, I then posted a series of
questions kind of like Martin Luther on
the Catholic Church's wall, if you will.
Not maybe not the perfect metaphor, but
you get the idea. Um, basically I posted
a series of questions on X to the Second
Amendment Foundation and the Firearms
Policy Coalition about how to understand
this decision because as I've explained
before, you know, I'm not the lawyer on
the case. I don't represent any of the
plaintiffs or the groups or anything
like that. And uh, you know, I can't
give legal advice because everyone has a
different situation. They go into
different post offices. They have
different membership status or lack
thereof, whatever it is. And that's why
I always tell people when it comes to
your particular situation, you need to
check with your own lawyers because
everyone's situation is different. I can
only give you kind of the big picture
framework of the way the law is working.
Uh but the specific details as applied
to you and your situation, you have to
get your own legal counsel. So with that
said, I did have a series of questions
for FPC and the Second Amendment
Foundation. So let's get to that in a
second. So before we do that, let me
give you the first post I made on X
laying out the win and then we're going
to get to my questions and then I'm
happy to report the Second Amendment
Foundation did specifically uh answer my
questions in writing on X and we'll get
to that in just one second. But to begin
with, here was my announcement just a
couple of days ago announcing this huge
win for the Second Amendment. Thank you.
Uh, of course, Firearms Policy
Coalition, Second Amendment Foundation,
and the other plaintiffs in that case,
uh, that won for our rights to keep and
bear arms in US Post offices against the
federal government. So, check out my
post announcing the big win here.
Massive 2A win just now in Second
Amendment challenge to federal post
office gun ban. Federal court grants
relief to all current and future members
of the Firearms Policy Coalition and the
Second Amendment Foundation. In a
challenge to gun bans in US post
offices, there does not appear to be any
geographical limits of scope of relief
to the members. Judge Okconor wrote,
quote, "The court grants in part
defendants motion and the permanent the
permanent injunction as set forth in the
court's order number 35 and the final
judgment number 36 applies to plaintiffs
and to all present and future members of
Firearms Policy Coalition Inc. and
Second Amendment Foundation." Now, after
that came out, I posted on X what I
would ask the Second Amendment
Foundation what I would ask the Firearms
Policy Coalition if I were a member or I
were considering to become or I was
thinking about becoming a member. Um,
here is what I asked them on X. Check it
out. Team 2A important information about
the huge Second Amendment US Post Office
win today. Here are the questions you
should ask the Firearms Policy Coalition
and the Second Amendment Foundation
about today's huge 2A victory involving
the ban on carrying firearms into
federal post offices. First, am I a
member of your organization?
Please provide me with documentary proof
so that I can carry it with me into post
offices. Second, I asked if I am not a
member of your organizations, then does
the injunction apply to me? Then I asked
third, does this injunction apply to all
post offices all across the United
States? Are there exceptions? And if
yes, what exceptions are there? Then I
ask fourth, do we know whether the US
government will treat this injunction as
a preeemption to an arrest or as an
affirmative defense to a post arrest
indictment? Can we get clarification
from the Department of Justice on this
point? And fifth, what happens if an
appellet court overturns this
injunction? What do I need to know and
how would I find out about it? And
lastly, but not leastly, do you have any
practical tips of carrying it in US
postal offices moving forward? So, those
were my questions I posed. That's the
sort of thing I thought was important to
at least get a sense from the
organizations who have their own
lawyers, of course, uh what do they
think? And I'm sure they vetted this
with all their attorneys that were
involved in the case, the behind the
scenes, all that kind of stuff. They
have uh very sophisticated organiz
sophisticated organizations there. So
that was my questions posed because I
thought they were the questions that
should be asked and you should get
answers to. And I'm happy to report that
the Second Amendment Foundation did
indeed answer the questions. In fact,
here's what they said. Major breaking
news. We answer Mark's questions here.
read on so you can be the smartest
person in the room. See, even if I ask
questions on X, it's major breaking news
and you get to be the smartest person.
Even the Second Amendment Foundation and
Costas Moros over there at 2 AF agrees.
Hey, what can you say? Anyway, very
funny stuff. But let's go on to the
specific answers. We answer Mark's
questions here to the first question,
which is, "Am I a member of your
organization? Please provide documentary
proof." They say number one, here's
their answer. If you would like to join
SAF or renew your membership, visit our
website. It's only $25 per year. If you
do not recall if you are a member or
not, you can inquire at info@saf.org.
It's a good answer. Perfectly fine. That
makes sense. Now, some people have said,
"Why do I have to join these
organizations to exercise my Second
Amendment rights?" It's a fair question.
It's not illegitimate. But the reality
is this. If you were an African-American
tried to protect your rights in the
1950s and the 1960s in the segregated
South, many would join the National
Association for the Advancement of Color
People, the NAACP.
Why? Because they wanted to benefit from
the legal wins the NAACP secured and
related civil rights groups secured. So
again, I'm not saying we live in utopia.
We don't live in the world of rainbows
and unicorns. That's why the Four Boxes
Diner channel exists. If we all lived in
utopia, you wouldn't need this channel
or lawyers at all. But that's not the
world we live in. So to maximize the
chances of exercising your rights, there
are strong arguments for joining
organizations that in turn win for your
rights that allow you to exercise them.
Am I saying the system is perfect? No,
I'm not. But again, this is the world in
which we live and that is the world we
have to function in for better or for
worse. So with that said, let's turn to
their second question or I should say
their answer to my second question right
here. I then asked, "If I am not a
member of your organization, then does
the injunction apply to me?" And SAF
said, "Nope, you must become a member
for the injunction to apply to you?"
Three, and this is the third question I
asked it, as you know, I asked, "Does
the injunction apply to all postal
services or all post offices across the
United States? Are there exceptions? And
if so, what are the exceptions? And what
do they say? Quote, it applies to all
post offices except those that are
contained in a location where carry is
otherwise prohibited for a separate
reason. For example, if the post office
is on a military base, you cannot carry
there. That's great. That's what how I
read it, too. There don't appear to be
any geographical restrictions. So if
you're a member of the Second Amendment
Foundation or the Fires Policy
Coalition,
it applies nationwide. It's a permanent
injunction against the federal
government at the benefit of the
plaintiffs, the organizations, and the
members of those organizations. Because
understand, as a member of these
organizations, you've come together to
fight for your rights. No different than
the NAACP in the 1950s and 1960s. But
let's move on to the fourth question and
answer from the Second Amendment
Foundation. I asked, "Do you know
whether the US government will treat
this injunction as preeemption to an
arrest or as an affirmative defense to a
post arrest indictment? Can we get
clarification from the DOJ on this
point?" And SAF says, quote, "That's up
to the Department of Justice, not us. We
urge them to stop enforcing this
unconstitutional law entirely and not
just against SAF members." So again, we
don't know what the Department of
Justice is going to do. What they should
do is to not enforce this. Will they try
to enforce this and arrest someone if
they're caught with a gun in a post
office? Will they arrest that person and
then force you in court to demonstrate
that you're a member and then letting
you off at that point? That is the
difference between a preeemption law or
a preemptive law, preeemption law versus
an affirmative defense. An affirmative
defense is something you assert against
an indictment or against a claim in
court. uh preeemption basically says you
can't even go to court in the first
place. As to how DOJ is going to treat
this, I have no way of knowing, but it's
just something to be aware of. So, let's
go to the next question I asked dealing
with what happens if an appellet court
overturns this win for the Second
Amendment. The Second Amendment
Foundation says, quote, "Follow SAF for
any updates. We will promptly get word
out if the injunction is stayed or
reversed by an appellet court. But we
urge the DOJ to quit defending this
unconstitutional law and accept defeat
here. Here I agree this is exactly what
should happen. The DOJ should stop
enforcing this law. I know it's a tough
job. I know under article two of the
constitution the president and the
executive branch including the
department of justice has like a
constitutional duty uh to take care uh
to faithfully execute federal law. That
is the general presumption. the DOJ
defends these federal laws. Uh but with
that said, they this is there is some
wiggle room there as to what laws you
push and what laws you don't. And I
would urge DOJ to kind of use some
discretion here and let this one slide.
Now, last but not least, I asked the SAF
and Firearms Policy Coalition if there's
any practical tips. Here's what they had
to say. SCF says, quote, "Finally,
remember that while we will pass along
all updates as we receive them, anyone
with questions about the legality of
their conduct should consult an
attorney." should consult an attorney.
As always, that's great advice. Again,
when it comes to your specific
situation, you need to get your own
advice. Uh because everyone is
differently situated. They have
different, you know, pasts, different
histories, uh different ages, different
post offices, different jurisdictions.
Obviously, uh there's certain people in
certain post offices in certain
jurisdictions that are probably more
friendly to the Second Amendment than
other jurisdictions. So, just something
to be aware of uh as you move forward.
But anyway, this is a huge win for the
Second Amendment. I think there will be
a lot more to come. Uh but with that
said, this is the world in which we live
and I think the trend is our friend
except in those handful of terrible
anti-gun jurisdictions where all the
anti-gun billionaire money is flowing to
a handful of jurisdictions because those
are the only places where they can make
a difference to advance the anti-gun
agenda because in so much of America
it's dead on arrival and all that money
that could be sent by the anti-guners is
being focused on a handful of
jurisdictions where the Democrats
control the governor's mansion, the
courts, the house and the state uh
senate. of those particular states. And
that's why we're seeing this push for
gun control laws in a handful of
jurisdictions like Virginia, uh, New
Mexico, Colorado, Washington State,
California, the usual suspects. All
right, there you have it, folks. Hope
you enjoyed today's episode. Make sure
you follow me on X at Baroxire. Don't
forget to subscribe, both the YouTube
and the Rumble, and I'll see you all
again real soon here at the Barox.
>> Orders up. Table 2A.